le Québec va mieux la situation
économique et financière s'améliore les
résultats de nos actions sont positifs
et rassurants en retrouvant l'équilibre
budgétaire nous retrouverons notre
liberté de faire nos choix les nouvelles
sont sont sont encourageantes en ce qui
concerne redressement des finances
publiques les données montrent une
amélioration graduelle de la situation
financière du
gouvernement bien revenons à cette mise
à jour économique du ministre des
Finances du Québec Carlos letao on vous
en donn les grandes lignes tout à
l'heure le gouvernement qui maintient le
cap vers l'atteinte de l'équilibre
budgétaire le pire est fait dit même le
ministre l'AO 85 % des mesures
nécessaires au redressement des finances
publiques sont maintenant identifiées
est-ce que le ministre a mis ses
lunettes roses Michel les Québécois donc
pourront-ils souffler un peu est-ce que
le pire est vraiment derrière nous
maintenant vous qui êtes à la
l'Assemblée nationale qui avait suivi ça
aujourd'hui ben le le pire est pas
encore arrivé c'est-à-dire que toutes
ces ces coupures là qui ont été
identifiées ont pas encore frapper les
gens ou les les organismes qui vont être
touchés euh c'est c'est la partie la
plus facile qui a été faite si on peut
dire dans la mesure où là on a on a
aligné des colonnes de chiffres on a
identifié des endroits où on voudrait
couper mais maintenant il s'agit de
couper dans la réalité des choses vous
savez je sais pas là ça fait plusieurs
fois qu'on essaie de de réduire la rémun
effectifs dans la fonction publique ça a
jamais marché là on nous dit que ça va
générer des centaines de millions mais
il faudra voir la réforme des structures
dans la santé monsieur Barret nous dit
que ça va être très payant mais on n pas
encore vu cet argentl les commissions
scolaire on sait pas si ça va donner de
l'argent ou ça va coûter bref c'est loin
d'être assuré on sera dans le fond dans
dans un an et demi au 31 mars 2016 si
vraiment on a atteint l'objectif Daniel
tous les partis sontend en fait pour
dire qu'il faut remettre de l'ordre dans
les finances publiques mais que c'est
une opération nécessaire mais est-ce
qu'on va un peu trop vite et trop loin
est-ce que on aurait pas pu attendre un
peu ouais ben écoutez il a il y a des
gens cet après-midi qui disaient bon
pourquoi ne pas attendre un an peut-être
un peu plus avant de de de rêver
d'atteindre l'équilibre budgétaire sauf
que est-ce que le gouvernement a
vraiment les moyens d'atteindre vous
l'avez dit tous s'entendre pour dire
qu'il faut assignir les finances
publiques que ce serait irresponsable de
ne pas s'y est-ce qu'il y a des dangers
oui la question que vous posez est est
est pertinente danger de brusquer les
gens d'y aller trop rapidement avec des
conséquences sociales que vous
connaissez danger aussi de de de de trop
retirer d'argent de d'une économie
extrêmement fragile certains parlent
même d'une récession si on va trop loin
danger aussi de créer une sorte de chaos
administratif avec tous ces changements
qui surviennent tout d'un coup de toutes
part et et et de tout côtés problème
c'est que le gouvernement n'a pas le
choix vaut mieux le faire en début de
mandat pour des raisons politiques que
vous connaissez et s'il ne le fait pas
il y a il y a le danger aussi de se
faire taper sur les doigts sérieusement
par les agences de crédit mais tacha
est-ce qu'il y a pas un danger de se
mettre la population à de à dos parce
qu'encore une fois les contribuables
vont beaucoup contribuer 262 millions là
qui vont devoir contribuer dans les
annonces d'aujourd'hui oui ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le gouvernement
met tout le monde à dos il y a personne
qui est épargné dans cet exercice le
gouvernement avait deux choix
essentiellement soit coupé dans la
fonction publique coup dans les services
pour économiser de l'argent à l'état ou
augmenter les revenus en augmentant les
impôts ce qu'ils ont fait sur les
particuliers sur les sociétés les
institutions financières ils ont essayé
je pense de d'éparpiller la douleur un
petit peu partout euh ce qui rend tout
le monde frustré et ça va on va voir
dans 3 ans si les gens auraient oublié C
cet exercice et la douleur qui s'en
vient avec je pense que si l'économie
s'améliore oui mais autrement euh ils
vont dire que c'est c'était le mauvais
choix écoute il reste à voir moi je
pense que c'est certainement pas un
exercice de création d'emploi ça c'est
sûr parce que les impôts ça va nuire à
cela ouais c'est pas un exercice de
création d'emploi où est-il l'effet
libéral dont Monsieur Couillard avait
parlé Michel ben on l'attend toujours
écoutez monsieur lard s'est trompé là
pour une deuxième fois de suite dans ses
prévision d'emploi c'està-dire qu'on on
les on créera pas les emplois qu'on
espérait en 2014 et nous Anons que la
l'objectif pour 2015 est aussi révisé à
la pissce le résultat net c'est que à la
fin de l'an prochain il y aura pas plus
d'emplois que qu'en
2013 de sorte que et c'est là le danger
c'est que si la reprise arrive pas on
pourra pas couper des milliards des
milliards comme ça pendant des années
parce que on a beau atteindre le déficit
théoriquement disons en 2015 16 ben en
16 17 on pourra pas recommencer à couper
encore si l'économie génère pas les
revenus suffisants alors ce ce qu'on
qu'on entend aujourd'hui de la bouche de
Monsieur L au plan de la la relance
économique c'est c'est beaucoup plus
inquiétant que rassurant et et l'autre
coup de Jarnac qui peut qui peut arriver
est tomber sur la tête du gouvernement
du Québec comme sur la tête des
gouvernements des autres provinces c'est
au niveau de la péréquation si les prix
du pétrole continuent de s'effondrer et
reste à un niveau très très bas pendant
très très longtemps c'est beaucoup moins
d'argent qui viendra du gouvernement
fédéral il y a un bon côté à ça les
économies de l'Ontario et du Québec vont
en profiter mais avant qu'on voit les
signes encourageant avant qu'on voit des
signes de reprise de ces deux économies
ça risque de prendre beaucoup de temps
et et ce dont parlait Michel au début
est-ce que le pire est passé le pire
peut devenir récurrent pour quelques
années ce qui ne serait sûrement pas euh
ne ferait sûrement pas le bonheur ni de
la population ni du gouvernement
Couillard bon c'est jamais facile
évidemment de vendre entre guillemets
l'austérité mais il y a la la grogne a
commencé la grogne sociale a commencé
plusieurs dénoncent l'absence de
dialogue avec la population euh on
semble vouloir imposer ses compressions
tacha comment est-ce que le gouvernement
va-t-il parvenir à calmer le jeu mais le
gouvernement écoute a fait campagne sur
le nettoyage des Finances du Québec on
savait c'était c'était pas en bon état
peut-être pas aussi pire que CELI
actuellement alors la population a voté
pour ce ménage on naime jamais le ménage
quand il s'en vient d'ailleurs on a vu
l'austérité dans les pays européens
c'est c'est la même sorte de grogne qui
s'installe le gouvernement pour pour le
calmer ça va simplement être les les
faits essentiellement si l'économie
relance si on atteint le déficit zéro et
on voit une augmentation de de
l'activité économique là ça va estomper
c'est c'estes critique mais juste pour
revenir sur le pétrole c'est intéressant
que le gouvernement a maintenu la bourse
de carbone on va voir une augmentation
environ de de sous je pense le litre
tandis que le prix est bas peut-être ça
va pas faire si mal mais quand même
c'est un choix de société et être vert
ça coûte de l'argent est-ce que le
Québec peut-être doit rviser ces
choix-là c'est ça le gouvernement n'a
pas fait ces décisions de de C en
vigueur faut il faut pas refaire
l'histoire trop trop euh de façon trop
trop marquée là le gouvernement a fait
relativement peu campagne sur le les
libéraux je devrait dire sur le ménage
ça c'était la caque qui faisait ça les
libéraux disaient nous allons générer de
la croissance économique de sorte que on
va pouvoir arriver à l'équilibre
budgétaire sans alourdir le fardau des
contribuables alors là c'est pas ça du
tout ce qui
on sait jamais on sait jamais quand
est-ce que je vous disais tantôt c'est
facile d'écrire des choses dans un Budet
souvenez-vous au printemps 2012 qui
aurait pensé que la petite relativement
enfin pensait le gouvernement
augmentation des frais de scolarité que
Monsieur bachin avait inscrit dans son
budget donnerait ce qu'on a vu au
printemps 2012 alors il a il y a des
ferments grogne je vous dis pas que ça
va aller jusque là on n est pas là mais
une semaine avant que ça ça parte en
2012 personne pensait qu'on arrivvera là
non plus il y a toujours il y a toujours
ce problème de communication dont vous
parlez Céline et et c'est jamais facile
de critiquer les politicien trop
ouvertement nous dit toujours qu'on est
cque et cetera et cetera mais si vous
regardez la façon dont le gouvernement
Couillard a vendu ce programme là à la
population il y a peut-être pas choisi
les meilleurs acteurs ga arret projette
l'image de quelqu'un qui arrive toujours
avec ses gros sabots on peut parler
longuement des ratés du ministre Yve
baluc Martin Quatu on s'entend tous pour
dire que c'est quelqu'un de super
intelligent de super compétent mais il
jette l'image de quelqu'un d'arrogant et
de suffisant l'impression en politique
est toujours extrêmement importante
c'est toujours ça que les gens
retiennent d'abord et l'impression
qu'ils ont c'est que ce gouvernement là
s'en va en ligne droite sans sans se
préoccuper des gens même Philippe
Couillard donne l'impression d'être
au-dessus tout ça allez-y on y va on
fonce sans trop se préoccuper des
retombées ouais mais j'allaai dire en
Ontario en 2003 on a vécu la même sorte
de choses avec le gouvernement libéral
élu sur une promesse de ne pas augmenter
les impôts leur excuse pour le faire
c'était ce que que c'était pire qu'il
pensait quand ils sont rentrés les
finances de la province ils ont été élus
pendant ils ont été élus réélus ils sont
toujours là alors c'est ça veut pas dire
simplement qu'ils ont brisé la promesse
que ça ne va pas ils vont pas rester au
pouvoir pour le bien ou le pire mais
Michel quand même on nous fait miroiter
des surplus en
2017-28 des baisses d'impôts aussi on
sera en année électorale oui mais les
les impôts fait les surplus qu'on nous
fait miroiter c'est peut-être he si tout
va bien 450 millions la moitié au fond à
la dette il reste quoi 200 millions vous
savez ça fait pas des gros gros bonbons
électoraux ça 200 millions et et ça
c'est si tout va bien parce que si
l'économie continue à être aussi pousive
que ça et n'oublions pas non plus qu'il
y a des des coupur dans les transferts
ou dans l'augmentation des transferts de
santé du gouvernement fédéral qui vont
arriver exactement à ce moment-là alors
c'est encore très loin là pour pour
commencer à à budgeter nos retours
d'impôt de 2018 là c'est encore trop
loin Daniel c'est c'est un peu loin oui
moi je miserai pas là-dessus je ferai
pas de gros achat en me disant je vais
recevoir beaucoup d'argent du
gouvernement dans 3 ans je pense que
j'attendrai peut-être un peu tacha je
pense que écoute le gros la grosse
question ça va être les emplois et si on
continue à ne pas voir la la croissance
économique des emplois au Québec ça ne
va pas marcher parce que les revenus
c'est c'est essentiellement ce qu'ils
veulent faire c'est un but à court terme
mais à long terme ça pourrait nuire au
progrès économique alors ben merci à
vous d'avoir été là un mardi vous avez
congé de leçon et devoir jeudi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine
beauoup